[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy that's
had breakfast for dinner for the last
nine weeks
due to one division taking up all my
friday mornings
we're all grieving for the show being
over now but that just feels like it
might be love persevering
and throughout this video we're going to
be discussing our favorite easter eggs
from the season
we start off with wonder and vision
driving into the town of west view
and get a minor glimpse at the sign this
would of course come to change
throughout the season
but the name westview itself has a
number of cool little things in it
firstly the two words in the town start
with a w and v
which are also the initials of wonder
and vision the word tv is also in the
middle of the name
and taking a west view of the world
means that you have an altered
perception of it
we later see at the end of episode 4
that the slogan is home
it's where you make it and this hints to
how wonder made the hex
the first episode parodies the dick van
dyke show and this of course appears
later on episode 8. the title called for
both the series are very similar
but whereas in the intro for the dick
van dyke show dick tripped over the
footstool
vision passes through the chair vision's
tie has a strange symbol on it
and this contains two dots inside a
rectangular shape
if we take these to be a representation
of wonder and vision then the rectangle
could be a symbol for the hex itself and
the two dots on the outside could
represent agatha and hayward
who are both somewhat the villains of
the show though agatha all along is so
good
i really can't stay mad at her now in
the kitchen
vision is hit in the head with a plate
and wonder makes a joke about him having
an indestructible head
this is a joke because well the lad gave
thanos a piece of his mind stone
and it got ripped out of his head
killing the character in the process
the pale look at a calendar with a horde
symbol on it above the 23rd
and this is likely a reference to the
deed that we see in episode 8
in which we learn that the vision bought
the house and put a heart symbol on it
with a cute cute little message i'm not
crying i swear now
the the 23 that could also be
referencing the 23 mcu movies that
preceded the series
and in general 23 is seen as a number
that is key to everything
don't even get me started on that jim
carrey movie now it's not too long
before agnes the nosy neighbor shows up
and the first hint that she's agatha
hawkins is her name
which if you take the first and last
letters of and put them together
you get agnes i swear i swear that's the
last time i'll use that easter egg
you can rest now i get that also says
the word charmed a typical phrase
associated with witches and states her
wedding anniversary tour office on the
2nd of june
which was the start of the salem witch
trials agnes
also teaches wonder seduction techniques
because
as we learn she really wants wonder and
vision to have
kids this comes from a magazine titled
glamorous
and a glamour is basically a spell that
makes people seem appealing
potentially hinting to agatha being
someone that seems
nice yeah it's a reach now that night
visions boss mr heart comes over
and his wife is played by deborah joe
rupp who is sitcom royalty after
featuring in that 70s show
one that actually welcomes mr hart by
putting her hands over his
eyes and this is said to be a sokovian
greeting later on in episode eight we
see wonders mother puts her hands over
her eyes
and this could be a call back to that
moment and how she feels within her home
wanda ends up making breakfast for
dinner and this is mocked by agatha at
the end of episode 8
when she says she could be using her
powers for more important things
when the wine bottle is being poured we
can also see the words maison du me pre
which translates to house of contempt
the neck of the bottle has the letter m
on it though
and as may pre starts with an m we can
take this as being house of
m which is of course a graphic novel
that the show pulls from
there's a famous cover in that which has
wander's face appear in almost a
terrorist-like manner
this style not only shows up when wonder
is building the house in episode 8 as a
way for the bricks to connect
but monica is too put together in a
similar fashion
when she's brought back by the blip mr
hall gets angry and says there's so much
chaos going on in the house
and shout outs to cj miller for pointing
out that this is likely a reference to
the chaos magic
that we later learn wonder pulls from
jump to the commercials and we see a
toaster made by stock industries
that when powered up makes a similar
sound to the arc reactor charging
there's also a blinking red light in the
middle of it that looks very similar to
the one on the missile that wonder
encountered as a kid
these commercials could also represent
certain aspects of the infinity stones
and due to the toastmate 2000 looking
like a face the light could be seen as
the mine stone
that might be a reach but vision was
actually given the nickname toaster in
the comics
so i'll take back my hand put it in my
pocket and let you know yeah
there's no reaching here there's no more
allowed i'll cut to episode two
and we get an animated intro that starts
off with the moon and stars
these form the shape of a hexagon and
the intro as a whole mimics the one from
bewitched in several ways
bewitched followed a witch as she tried
to hide her powers from the world
and the house from it actually appears
later in the series as agatha's home
we can also spot the grim reaper's
helmet who has appeared throughout a
number of comics centering around the
pair
and the amount of times i spent
theorizing that he was going to be in
the show
i don't even want to get into it now in
the intro we move through the town
and see a supermarket that has a kitty
litter advert named auntie aze
agatha actually refers to herself as
anti-agnes later on in the series
likely tying back to this advert someone
actually pointed out to me that agnes is
like kitty litter because she's full of
[ __ ]
i feel so bad because i forgot to
screenshot the name of the person who
came up with that joke to give them
credit
but you know who you are and we'll just
have to call you the silent guardian
the watchful protector that i don't have
to say thank you to uh
because i'm taking all the credit i'm
gonna be honest now there's also one for
boba milk
who in the comic books was a mutated cow
that delivered wonders kids
i'm not even kidding on that either and
if you don't believe me you can suck
boba dee's nuts now when the cartoon
characters arrive in the home
agatha is the only one who gets inside
the house whilst the others wait outside
it
hinting to how she has more power than
they do wonder envisions start
practicing their magic act
under the name glamour and illusion this
actually calls back to the comic book
vision and the skull at witch
in which there was a magical pair of the
same name who popped up from time to
time
the magic cupboard also has the mine
stone on it and we cut outside to see a
toy helicopter in the bush
which we learn in episode four is one of
the drones that's sort of sent in
we meet agatha not long after and her
rabbit senor scratchy
in the comics agatha's son was called
nicholas scratch
and this bunny's name is likely a
reference to that too
rabbits are also typically a symbol
associated with procreation
and thus agatha carrying this instead of
her typical black cat
could be the reason for the chainship in
the comics agatha's cat is also called
ebony
i don't know if this is a reach i know i
said no more reaching
but it might be a bunny because ebony
the cat a bunny the rabbit don't don't
at me on that
moving on we cut to the advert and we're
introduced to this struck a watch
strucker was the name of the scientist
that experimented on her and her brother
when she was younger
and these ads very much signify a trauma
in wonder's life
and also happen in chronological order
with the missile coming first
before the experimentation and so on due
to its centering on time
i think this is supposed to represent
the time stone but let me know below if
you disagree
now the talent show is thrown for the
children but as we notice the longer the
season goes on
there aren't really any kids in west
view at one point we see phil
playing the piano and in episode 8 we do
see him hanging up an advert for piano
lessons
wonder then becomes pregnant and fast
forwards time to the 70s
which is when we get a brief tour of her
house during this we can see that she
has wallpaper on it that showcases the
castle from age of ultron
which massively ties back to the first
film that she appeared in
cartoon episode 3 and we see the 70s
entry the title card of which is similar
to brady bunch
but instead of using squares they use
hexagons
the house itself is of course modeled on
the brady bunch home
and we're also introduced to dr nielsen
in tv
nielsen ratings refer to an audience
size and growth for any given show
and him getting this name is a nice
little easter egg in the intro we also
catch wonder reading the glamorous
magazine
but this time it's been updated to fit a
70s design
you also see vision who's reading an
occult looking pregnancy book
and he does this while standing in front
of an appliance store
this mashing up of the two hints to how
he's actually a machine
that's trying to become a father when
they're in the nursery vision quotes
william shakespeare
and says the whole world's a stage
referring to how everyone in the hex
world is putting on an act because of
wonders
control wonder says she has butterflies
in her stomach
and this triggers the mobile to come to
life with butterflies
hinting at how she's able to alter
reality and is the one behind it all
after the subliminal hints in episode 2
there's also several in this episode
that hinted the big bad trying to make
wonder manifest twins
the first of these comes with vision
building a swing set with two swings
and a seesaw which you know has to be
operated by two people to work properly
we also cut to phil's house and see that
his lamp has two babies on it
there's then a bright light that shines
in the house during the midpoint of the
episode
and this is likely the spotlights firing
up that we see sword have at the end of
the entry
cut to the commercial and we're
introduced to hydra soak
not only does this blue box potentially
represent the tesseract
it also calls back to agents of shield
when colson discussed that hydro
develops soap
which could control your mind the ad
itself parodies several calgon
commercials from the 70s
including the take me away one this has
a woman standing in front of four video
screens
saying that she wants to be taken away
and like the one in one division we cut
to her in a bath
the commercial also has two kids in it
now further enforcing the idea that this
is the episode that wonder will have
twins in
wonder gives birth to her two babies and
the second one
is a complete surprise this is actually
a reference to the vision and skull at
which graphic novel
as in that doctor strange didn't realize
that wonder was going to have twins
until she popped them both out it's also
in this episode that wonder figures out
who monika is
and she notices her sword necklace which
we learn in episode 4
is actually her id badge agatha also
enforces the notion that moniker is
someone that needs to go
and this is because she starts to become
aware of what's going on
this also plants the idea in vision's
head that he needs to start looking
closer at his wife
which eventually makes him leave so that
agatha can swoop in
and offer to babysit the kids when it
gets too much for wonder
if vision was still in the house in
episode 8 then he would look after them
instead of her
and in the words of joker it's all part
of the plan
monica is thrown outside the hex and we
hear this song daydream believer by the
monkeys
and it also seems that monica is waking
up in some way
up until this point monica has believed
the daydream that she's been in
but now outside the hex she's awakened
to the truth
episode 4 flips the script and it's at
this point that we see things from
monica's perspective
this is by far my favorite opening of
any episode
and we learned that because of the snap
she was robbed of saying goodbye to her
mother
though not identical this mirrors
wander's journey
who to return with the blip only to find
that the one person she cared about more
than anything
simply wasn't there anymore on the whole
low the world is very happy
and when monica returns to sword we can
see that there's a new show discussing
how the blip brings loved ones back
in the report we can see two women
hugging potentially a mother and
daughter
which is somewhat of a slap in the face
to monica who never got to say goodbye
to her mum
monica tries to open the door with her
id but this doesn't work
and it very much juxtaposes how wanda
just blasts through the same door
later on in the season showing their
differences and powers and abilities at
this point
maria's plaque also displays her
nickname photon
which was first seen on her jet all the
way back in captain marvel
monika also goes under this moniker
establishing how she's carrying on her
mother's mission here
occur to her arriving outside the hex
and we're introduced to jimmy woo
who does a card trick this was of course
set up in ant-man and the wasp
where he was fascinated by scott's magic
moniker flies a drone in
and on it we can see the colours of
captain marvel
jump back to her solo film and you might
remember that monica
helped her to choose these as a kid
showing that the colors have stuck with
her for a long time
monica gets sucked into the hex where
reintroduced to darcy
and swords start their investigation
which leads to them iding people from
the town
agatha's id isn't present because she's
of course operating under a fake name
so she's pretty much impossible to track
down though i'm not sure they could
even if they knew who agatha was we also
learned that the hex is using
cmbr which is radiation that dates back
all the way to the big bang
and this could be due to wonders power
drawing from the infinity stones
which we discovered in infinity war were
created along with it
throughout this episode we discovered
that it was jimmy wu who did the
broadcast in episode
2 but from the outside we see how
dotty's reaction
and blood was completely edited out of
the show this not only happened with the
vision in the prior episode
but also in this one when moniker is
tossed out of the hex
a cool little detail happens when she's
thrown out as she passes through four
walls
and shout outs to new rock stars for
noting that this is likely due to this
scene literally breaking the fourth wall
and taking us to the outside world the
song which ends the episode is voodoo
child which could not only be
referencing the twins who gain abilities
but also wonder herself who we discover
in episode 8
had powers as a child episode 5 sees us
return to the sitcoms
and we join wonder and the vision in the
80s themed entry
there's a cool little callback to family
ties as that sitcom had a sofa with one
blue cushion on it
which we also see that wonders has
agatha arrives and breaks character on
her own
without vision having to use the mind
stone showing that she is capable of
doing this anyway
agatha is present about times that the
kids age up
likely hinting to her being behind it
and she also wants to force them to a
third time
which is probably why she murders sparky
hashtag
never forget sparky itself was present
in the vision graphic novel
and originally it was a dog that was
called zeke who died after digging up
the grim reaper's corpse
the dog was then resurrected as a
synthesized one called sparky
and this is where the name originates
from agatha says kids you can't control
them
and this might be a reference to when
she was younger and her mother tried to
stop her from dabbling in dark magic
but it of course backfired every time
that we see billy and tommy
they also always wear the colors
associated with their comic book
counterparts
hammering home the idea that they will
become wiccan and speed
cut to the intro and this combines
several from the decade
the family painting thing is a nod to
the opening of family ties
and the thought of the cast growing up
through the airs is playing on when the
same thing happened in growing pains
in full house's intro there were shots
of the family running on a field of
grass
which two is present in the one division
copy
elizabeth olsen's real life twin sisters
actually starred in that show
so here we have a big meta joke about
her playing a parent and a parody of a
show
in which her twin sisters featured one
his kids themselves as well as evan
peters
also very much fit into the sitcom trope
known as cousin oliver syndrome
this is typically defined as when a
declining show decides to
introduce a new either funny or cute
character
in order to try and pull an audience
back in however this often goes badly
i tell you what cousin oliver i feel
badly for all the crap you had to go
through growing up
i'm sorry now cut back to the sword
facility and we're played footage by
hayward that shows wonder apparently
taking visions body
we learn that this is all actually
edited and that she didn't steal the
body
meaning that hayward was lying however
this shows similarities between wonder
and hayward
as both have carried out edits to seem a
certain way cementing that they both
control the information that they want
people to see
darcy also says vision is playing father
knows best and this is a nod to a sitcom
from 1954 that the first couple of
episodes of the show took influence from
speaking of influence vision frees norm
from his hypnosis
and he says you have to stop her not you
have to stop wonder
this pretty much means that it can be
applied to agatha as well
and in respect it's a really nice little
scene now we're halfway through the
video
and if you're enjoying it so far i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every week
now hayward sends in a drone with stock
industries written on it
which wonder destroys if we look at the
parallels of her life
and her children's lives as a whole we
can also see
why this is so triggering she and her
twin brother were of course
haunted by a stark industry missile when
they were younger
and with their parents they lived in
this bubble surrounded by sitcoms
until their lives drastically changed
because of this one event
wonder somewhat sees history repeating
itself with hayward sending in this
stock industry's missile to potentially
kill her and her kids
but rather than let the same thing
happen she takes matters into her own
hands
on the outside she makes all the
soldiers turn their guns on hayward
and this is something similar to what
magnio did in the first x-men movie
depending on what continuity you
subscribed to magneto is one of his
father
so this is like a cool father-daughter
moment
she also only goes after hayward and
says that she'll never let anyone take
vision from her again
and this of course sets up the reveal in
episode eight that he now owns vision's
body
go to the commercials and we see an
advert for lagos paper towels
this is the name of the city that opens
civil war up and we all know that wanda
made a huge mistake there that altered
the public's perception of the avengers
though i did initially think that this
was meant to be the reality stone
to the red liquid used in it on further
reflection i think it might represent
the power stone
as the towel has the power to clean up
even the biggest spells
available in all good shops now vision
starts to suspect
something is up and i absolutely love
how wanda rolls the credits instead of
facing the argument
the show has very much been about facing
up to the truth
even if it's painful i think this scene
is so well put together
evan peters is introduced as a recast
pietro
and he's very similar to uncle jesse
from full house
in both his attitude and dress next we
get to episode 6 the halloween themed
one
which is based on the chapter from
vision and the skull at witch
that features trick or treats that have
turned into the monsters they were
dressed as
we open up with a malcolm in the middle
intro that contains song lyrics which
tell wander to keep the illusion going
this entire entry adopts the fourth wall
breaking tropes that the show utilized
and pietro is pretty much
exactly how the big brother in the
series is portrayed
agatha also features wearing some jeans
with naughty written on them
hinting at her true identity throughout
the episode we also get a big clue that
she's a witch
because she dresses like one at one
point all of the characters in this
entry adopt their comic book accurate
costumes hinting towards their true
identities
which of course is revealed later on
with her
wonder says she's dressed as the
sakovian fortune teller
and this is a nod to her mother on the
comics magda who
actually was one pietro's hair is also
gelled up wildly
and the costume designer on the show
said this was done on purpose
as a reference to wolverine the
character also refers to the two kids as
devil's spawns
and this is a nod to how in the source
material it was actually mephisto that
created them
the phrase kick-ass is used and this is
also a callback to how evan peters and
aaron taylor johnson starred in that
movie together
before the pair went on to play
quicksilver in the sword base
monica jimmy and darcy are cast out and
shout outs to ryan from screen crush for
pointing out they sneak back into the
base
using poncho's similar how thor did in
his first solo film
the commercial has a claymation
character instead of the man and woman
who disappeared for this week's episode
and this could be a nod to the snap
and how people were dusted and brought
back the ad has a shark in it
and the purple shades that appear on his
surfboard are likely a reference to
agatha harkness
who's typically associated with this
colour the shark gives the boy who wears
red like wonder
yogurt that he's unable to open and this
could represent how agatha is keeping
wonder occupied
while she drains the life out of her
similar what she did to the witches
during 1693.
the boy is stuck on an island similar to
the bubble or the hex exists in
and as this commercial deals with death
it could be and not to the soul stone
we then see wonder and co walking in
front of the coronet cinema
which is showing the incredibles and the
parent trap the incredibles is about a
family of superheroes
which is very much the same as this
series and the parent trap involves
twins switching places
which could be a nod to the two pietros
vision goes to the outskirts of the town
namely ellis avenue which is likely a
reference to president ellis
who he met in iron man 3. vision comes
across agatha
who unlike everyone else is able to talk
and respond
before vision brings her out of his
slumber the character is lost
even though she lives in the city and
she also cackles like a witch at one
point
hinting to what's going on upon waking
up she goes for her broach which isn't
there
and pretty much plants the idea in
vision's mind that he should leave the
hex
probably so she can sink her clothes
into wonder her and pietro go to the
square and have a heart to heart
in which he convinces her that the hex
is something special
this is similar the story house of m as
in that we learn it was actually
quicksilver
that convinced her to create the fake
reality pietro appears to be dead at one
point
and we can also see the bullet holes in
his costume that the aaron taylor
johnson version died from
jump to episode 7 which follows the
mockumentary format that was made
popular in the 2000s
due to shows like the office and modern
family we start with wonder waking up in
her bed
and can see that vision's pillow and the
duvet are covered in hexagons
however her pillow isn't showing that
she's somewhat separate from the hex
and though she exists inside of it she's
not subject to the same rules as
everyone else
when she goes downstairs we see her
eating the cereal sugar snaps
and it could be possible that the snap
is a reference to what thanos did in
infinity war
there's also a maze on the back of the
box which might be a nod to how people
are trapped in the hex
the news we hear in the background is
broadcast by wnda
aka wonder and an nda is determined
media
used to keep people from talking about
things much like how wanda
has with the people in the hex now the
intro has similar music to the office
and the title cards look a lot like the
intro to the sitcom happy endings
which was directed by the russo brothers
in the intro we see a license plate with
the numbers 12
28 22 on and this is actually stan lee's
birthday
showing that the mcu is still making
references to him
even though he's gone he wants to see
what looks like a ransom note
showing that someone knows what wonder
has done and it's likely agatha
is behind this so she can make one to
feel guilty there's also a fishbowl that
appears with the words wonder on it
which may be a reference to the movie a
fish called wonder
on the calendar we also see a heart
symbol which has a callback to the one
on the calendar from episode 1
which was the first major plot point in
the show the title itself looks similar
to the font from modern family
and it's sad that after this episode no
more sitcoms stuff
now get to the outside of the hex and we
see darcy as an escaper
is tied to a car and this of course
calls back to how she was handcuffed to
one
in the previous episode hayward's
henchman is now a strong man
and the pair decide to leave after
vision freeze darcy of the illusion
as they try to head back to town they're
hit by literal roadblocks
likely from agatha stopping them from
returning from here the advert shows the
woman on the bench
and it discusses her depression this is
clearly a standing for wonder
who was struggling with grief after the
death of vision
she's given the prescription drug nexus
and wonder is actually known as a nexus
being
aka a person who's the same across all
realities the woman appears in a bed by
herself which mirrors wondered at the
start of the episode
and due to the red used in the ad and
the focus on realities
it's like this one is about the reality
stone agatha comes and gets the kids
and she wants wanda to look at her mole
which is typically the sign of a witch
she also talks about biting kids which
is likely playing upon the fact
that witches eat children during an
interview with wonder
someone from behind the camera talks and
if you pitch shift this it's actually
the voice of catherine han who of course
plays agatha
do you think maybe this is what you
deserve monica goes to the hex and
before doing so she puts numbers into a
spectrometer
which is an odd to her hero name from
time to time spectrum
if you chart these numbers on a graph
you also get a hexagon
and the front of the vehicle itself has
a hexagon shape on it
the cockpit itself could also be calling
back to captain marvel
when her mother flew into space and we
also hear quotes from that film as she
travels through the barrier again
her costume upon arriving looks pretty
similar to what she has in the comics
and it's likely that this is the first
iteration of it she heads to wonders
and ends up doing a superhero landing
like deadpool
but agatha shows up before she can snap
her out of reality
in agatha's wonder realizes that
something is up because it's not perfect
due to the cicada that's on the curtains
in the comics this was actually one of
the first forms that mephisto took
and it's also a nod to the silence of
the lambs when clarice realized who
buffalo bill was
we get agatha all along the song of the
century
and this is playing on the intro of the
monsters which the font for the skit is
very similar too
episode 8 opens with the marvel studios
logo which changes to purple
showing that we are now watching things
with agatha in control
agatha's magic is purple and this is
because she pulls from the dark
dimension
which we saw dumamu lived in in doctor
strange
the scene is very similar to agatha's
death in the comics in which he was
burned at the stake
by the salem seven kurta agatha's
basement and the runes are explained to
her
which also exist in hexagons you go
through wanda's life
namely her childhood and from here meet
her mother and father
her dad is called auric which could be
playing on the name eric
the real name of magneto who is her
father in the source material
we see her favorite sitcom is the dick
van dyke show and her favorite episode
is the walnut one
this centers around the main character
being stuck in a dream
whilst lots of weird things happen with
walnuts and this turned into a nightmare
much in the same way that the series has
we see the stark missile land
and this of course looks very similar to
the one that was shown in iron man
next up is wonders time in the hydra
labs i know it's difficult to think
about why she would have done this
captain america too let a german
scientist experiment on him
for the good of his country which is
likely how these moments were sold to
the people
wanna sees a vision of her future in the
mind stone and this is likely the final
form of the skull at which
which wonder is given as a name in this
episode
in herself she watches an episode of the
brady bunch with a doll in it
that vision actually practiced changing
diapers on all the way back in episode
3.
we see wonder after the events of civil
war and vision walks through the wall
similar to how he did in that movie
vision drops the best line in the mcu
and we we then see wonder enter sword
with a similar news report running
to what there was with monica's entry
vision is sprawled out in pieces
and this is a call back to the comics in
which his body was dismantled in the
west coast avengers
his memory was also wiped on this
similar white vision
and wonder says i can't feel you which
is of course a call back to infinity war
where the two said i just feel you to
one another one wander travels to
westview and recreates vision
giving him a massive dong the whole town
transforms and we also see an ad for the
lagos paper towels
with a woman snapping her fingers on it
similar to what thanos did
i get the calls here the scarlet witch
and you're some of the [ __ ]
that's the character's name there's also
no more please stand by in the credits
as this is the end of the sitcoms
bravo okay and under the finale where we
watch agatha
absorbing wanda's powers similar what
she did to the witches during her trial
throughout the episode we actually start
to see wonder with it similar to them
showing that her life force is being
absorbed wanda realizes that she has to
think outside the box
and hits agatha with a car which is a
similar move to what she pulled on tony
in civil war
during the airport scene upon examining
the wreckage
she sees agatha's boots and this wicked
witch of westview moment
is a clear call back to the wizard of oz
the wizard of oz has a similar aspect to
the show
in that a young woman travels into a
strange land
where people from the real world take on
different roles and of course the
villain of both is a witch
white vision comes down and he says
wonder which is the first thing that the
hex version
said upon materializing he grabs wanda's
head
and this is similar to what he did to
ultron when cutting off his means of
escape
elsewhere we learned that the entire fox
merger with disney which costs a lot of
company 71 billion dollars
was actually just to do a joke
ralph bona much better than the x-men
coming to the mcu that
it's what the fans wanted now boner is
actually a character in growing pains
and as he seems like he might be a
stoner i'll always refer to him as
stoner boner elsewhere white vision
tries to rip the mind stone out of the
hex version's head
and this is a callback to how thanos
killed him in infinity war
jimmy is taken captive by hayward but
after years of studying
sleight of hand he's able to steal a
cell phone and unlock his handcuffs
wanda journeys to the town square and
comes across the mailman who says
don't shoot me i'm just a messenger this
is something that he said to agnes in
episode two whilst making his rounds
likely showing that he's just in a loop
walking through the town and repeating
the same thing over and over
he did say that a bit about sparky
though so i'll let the lad off
now agatha reveals that wanda has a
whole chapter dedicated to her in the
darkhold
and we see a drawing of the skull at
which in it which wonder mimics the
appearance of during the final scene
the character also has a hexagon
surrounding her in the book
as well as the spells incantations that
we see being cast in the finale
agatha says that her power is far beyond
the sorcerer supreme
and this is why in the post-credits
scene wanda was able to read the dark
hold whilst also walking around
when strange did something similar in
his solo movie
he had to be asleep at the same time and
shout outs to darth rahul for pointing
that out
wonder test the heck's open but we see
that her family get ripped along with it
and the terrorist effect on them
further calls back to the house of m
cover that we talked about earlier
the family do their incredibles pose and
the kids end up using their powers
with speed stealing a hat from a god
similar to what quicksilver did in days
of future past
the two visions discussed philosophy in
the library and this was the location
that vision broke
all the way back in episode 2. this
moment also calls back to the comics in
which there were two versions of vision
similar what we see that fuse together
with one another wonder speed sneaks up
to agatha and plants illusions into her
mind
very similar to how she did to tony
stark and age of ultron
wonder goes into the illusion with her
and materializes a red crown
which looks very close to the one that
agatha's mother had
one it takes the battle to the sky and
after setting up runes around the hex
she's able to absorb back at this power
this notion of runes was of course set
up in agatha's basement
when she explained how magic worked this
idea of her teaching wanda something
does
semitine with the comics as she was a
mental figure there and going forward it
looks like
she might be one too now wonders costume
is very interesting
because it looks extremely similar in
style to magnetos from days of future
past
the family return home and say their
goodbyes and the one between wonder
envision is shot
exactly the same way as their exchange
in infinity war
during that scene they plan to run away
together and in many ways the hex has
been that dream life for them
now shout outs to ryan airy again i
really hate that lad for pointing out
that them standing at the window looking
out
is very similar to the way that fight
club finalizes
we've actually done a full breakdown of
all the easter eggs in that movie
so definitely check it out after this
now wonder leaves west view
and in the first post credits scene we
watch jimmy delegating jobs like tommy
lee jones in the fugitive
monica is summoned to the theater and on
the banner we can see that they're
showing the movie tan hauser gate
which is a reference to blade runner in
that roy betty a synthetic man like
vision
referenced this in his dying breath but
the conversation also focused on
journeying out amongst the stars
which we know monica will now be doing
in the post-credits scene we see
wanda at wondergoal mountain and she
sits in a cabin by the lake
shout outs to roman suderic on facebook
for pointing out that the markings on
wonders door come from a village in
slokovia
in slavic mythology baba yaga is a witch
who was also mentioned in ant-man in the
wasp
and potentially this could be the
scholar witch the bringer of the end of
the world
and it's likely something that wonders
gonna wrestle with we see her astral
projection
hear her children's voices and then the
theme for doctor strange comes in
which ends the series and sets up the
multiverse of madness
now that's the end of the video and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
below and i just want to give a huge
shout outs to all the easter egg hunters
who've been doing weekly breakdowns on
the show
since it started whether you're a real
reject
a new rock star or have a screen crush
on ryan aries mom
it's been beyond epic going through my
heavy spoilers with you
u3c films the sea which stands for
canadian lad
so so you sh you superhero nexus now if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
avengers end game
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointed out all the
easter eggs just like this video
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for sticking to the video i've been
paul
i'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you